let's just be honest the left controls
almost everything right the left
controls big media the left controls big
tech the left controls
uh hollywood the left controls higher
education the left controls big
corporations the left now controls big
sports i mean just watch the nba
right i don't watch the nba anymore
right but the the left controls the
congress right now the left controls the
white house
the one area they don't control and this
is this is the beauty of our great
country
the one thing they don't control is they
still don't control individuals we the
people still have individual liberties
individual rights so we can think for
ourselves
and express ourselves and speak out but
they're even trying to stop that with
the whole cancel culture
so and and finally maybe the one
institution
that they still don't control is state
and local government
we learned that the fbi was spying on a
presidential campaign
like that's not supposed to happen in
our great country a major party's
political
or presidential candidate their campaign
was being spied on by the other parties
justice department i.e the fbi jim comey
i mean
that's scary and and joe you you talk
about you know
all the misinformation it's funny too
because this is the other thing i take
away from from jinsaki's comment
they're the ones identifying
misinformation well how many times have
they been wrong on that
over the last four years they they told
us the protesters were peaceful
last summer they told us that
republicans defunded the police they
told us the dossier was real they told
us trump colluded with russia
bob mueller did a 30 million
investigation said that's not accurate
they told us trump cleared lafayette
square
uh for a photo op the inspector general
said that's not true
they told us how about this one hunter
biden was russian misinformation
holy cow we had an eyewitness tony
bobolinsky we had actual documents the
emails we had a laptop and we had the
fbi investigating it but somehow was
russian misinformation i mean
time and time again every major story
they told us was misinformation they
lied to us about it and now they're the
ones telling facebook oh you got to take
down this information
that's frightening if i could add a
couple to your list brett kavanaugh is a
rapist
the covington kids jesse smallette i
mean the list
the list goes on and on so as you are
seeing
sake say okay we're flagging things for
facebook or her other one last week
which was even worse in a way
which was if you're banned from one
social media site
you should be banned from all as if that
has anything to do with her with what
her job is
um i mean are you shocked like i think
i i'm not shocked right like i've been
doing this for a while i've been sensing
and warning about this stuff
but i think a certain amount of people
are like you know that voted for biden
because they had whatever their aversion
was to trump and the tweets or whatever
but i think a certain amount of people
actually are shocked right now like
how out of control this thing feels yeah
i think you're right dave
you're not because you follow and you
know all these these issues so well
um and frankly most of us in an elective
office who've been here
uh uh you know for a few years we
shouldn't be shocked either because we
we saw the trend we saw the irs target
conservatives we saw what the fbi
did to with the dossier with the trump
campaign and we saw what they did with
so we've seen all this sort of progress
so it it it's still frightening it's
still scary
but we sort of kind of saw some of this
coming um but i do think there are lots
of americans
who are very nervous about what they see
happening to liberty i talked with them
in our i was back in our district last
week
talking with with supporters and people
they're they're very nervous about what
they see
and how many times have you gotten the
line from someone who follows you you
see them at the airport or something
they come up to you and they'll say i'm
really nervous about our country
can our country because they love this
country they love the flag they love
what our country stands for they love
the people who sacrifice for our country
and
and and liberated the country and took
on the nazis and everything they love
all that
appropriately so but they are nervous
very nervous
very concerned about where the left
wants to take us
and um that never used to that didn't
happen 15 years ago in politics but now
you
you i get that every every time i'm
traveling to an airport
right there used to be a basic agreement
that america was fundamentally good and
then it's like okay we can
argue from a liberal perspective or a
conservative now now it's in essence
should this thing continue but backing
up to the big tech stuff for a little
bit
yeah so so breaking them up let's talk
about that for a little bit
what does that actually look like like
you want amazon basically
to have their server farm you know aws
as a
separate company than say the consumer
facing side that we all
you know buy our toilet paper on or that
sort of yeah
what i think should happen is we've
historically done this we got a hundred
years of antitrust law
we have historically done this through
the court process now
that is a slow process i would like to
speed that up because i see the danger
of big tech and i see
you know what we just talked about with
with the government pressuring big tech
to do certain things that the government
defines as misinformation
that's that's dangerous so i want that
process speeded up but what i don't want
and what makes me nervous is because i
think it would be a worse situation
is to instead of having it go through
the court system is to move it over to
the regulatory commission
because right now at the ftc the people
who run the ftc
are radical leftists becca schlatter is
a member on the fct
ftc commission she has said we should
use antitrust law to deal with systemic
racism
yeah yeah you and i would say no we
shouldn't and a hundred years of of
any trust law says no we shouldn't so
that scares me lena khan who's the new
chairman of the ftc
who by the way when biden nominated and
put up for nomination from the senate
didn't tell the senators which is
historically the way it's supposed to
work but he didn't tell the senators
that he was going to make her chairman
guess where she worked before she went
to the ftc as chairman
she was facebook or something right well
she worked there but more importantly
and more recently
she worked for jerry nadler david
cicilline hakeem jeffries all the people
who were the impeachment managers who
put together these bills my guess is
lena khan wrote the bills
that give all the power to the agency
she now chairs
i don't think that's a good thing for
dave rubin who believes in the first
amendment and
and jim jordan and the folks i get to
represent so that's my concern
let's let it work through the court
process but let's do it quicker because
as bad as it's getting and the and the
pace that big tech is going to limit our
freedoms
i want i want an answer soon and i think
justice thomas
is with us my guess is the courts with
us because they got to be
coney amy connie barrett justice elite
they got to be concerned with what they
see
when the press secretary for the united
states president steps up
at the white house briefing room and
says we're working with facebook to take
down people's posts and take down
information
so you basically see the judicial branch
i mean in essence the supreme court
because that's where this probably ends
up you you see that as the last firewall
right i mean at that point if nothing
else works
and to your point if you're if the whole
middle branch of government you know if
the if the congressional branch and all
the regulatory
people if they're all compromised it's
judicial or nothing
well but we could do something
legislatively but
frankly we're not in control i mean
right now the democrats have the house
they have the senate they have the white
house
and they're going to have the white
house until president trump runs and
wins in 2024 which i hope is
what's going to happen i think he's
going to have both so you think he's
doing it you think he's doing it i i i
do and i i've encouraged him too i mean
every time i talk to him i encourage him
to run um but the the the the truth is
we can't change anything right now so
all we can do is what you do
we can highlight every time they're
infringing on americans liberties and i
do it
every speech i give i all across our
district all across the country
every time i'm out talking i talk about
i just go to the first amendment i said
think about the first amendment
the liberties you have under the first
amendment every single
one of them has been assaulted by
government over the past several years
i mean you your your right to practice
your faith your right to assemble your
right to petition your government
freedom to press freedom of speech
every single one i use the example um
when i
uh when they're they're still churches
today dave that that
probably well my guess is in l.a county
they're probably still churches today
that a full congregation can't meet on
sunday morning
and and a few weeks this is probably now
what eight nine ten weeks ago
i spoke to think about your right to
assemble i spoke to the
new mexico republican party in amarillo
texas
because they had to go to texas to get
freedom they had to go to texas to be
able to assemble in the size they wanted
to assemble
because their democrat governor wouldn't
let him assemble
more than 149 people in the state of
mexico in new mexico so
that's crazy but and on and on it goes
so i think i think this is this is the
fundamental issue and and
i mean scares me to death scares me to
death so to that point
how concerned are you that just nobody
trusts the system anymore
that that's sort of where i'm getting
which is you know that's what the kids
call black pill that you just think
that the thing is so broken that nothing
could be done
and i always try to put a positive spin
on all this stuff and i want to do
solutions of course that's that's why i
do this
but i think a lot of people are just
like you know what i don't trust the
medical experts because of lockdowns and
masks anymore
i don't trust the politicians who say
one thing about elections
when their guys in and the other the
other way like that that the whole
system it only works if we trust it and
and a lot of people just don't trust it
anymore yeah and i'm very concerned
about that
and it's um when you have and again i
think most of the blame
frankly lies with what with the left the
left as
is is has attacked every institution we
have
and frankly let's just be honest the
left controls almost everything right
the left controls big media the left
controls big tech the left controls
uh hollywood the left controls higher
education the left controls big
corporations
the left now controls big sports i mean
just watch the nba right
i don't watch the nba anymore right but
the left controls the congress right now
the left controls the white house
the one area they don't control and this
is this is the beauty of our great
country
the one thing they don't control is they
still don't control individuals we the
people still have individual liberties
individual rights so we can think for
ourselves
and express ourselves and speak out but
they're even trying to stop that with
the whole cancel culture
so and and finally maybe the one
institution
that they still don't control is state
and local government
and that's why what what uh desantis is
doing in
in florida with the florida legislature
what they're doing they're pushing back
in our federal system that's how the
founders and god bless these individuals
put our system together
there are not only checks and balances
with the separate equal branches of
government
there's the federalist system where the
checks and balances also come from the
states
and that's where we have to fight back
now and we're having some governors
who are doing it and i think that's
giving um some more courage to other
governors particularly other republican
governors
to step up and act like desantis is
doing in florida and push back on the
crazy left and
and the policies they want if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click
the notification bell